a lot of people are asking because they
love me and they ask me about a man
named John McCain and if you want that
to tell you about it should I or not yes
yes so I have to be honest I've never
liked them much hasn't been for me I've
really probably never will but there are
certain reasons for it and I'll tell you
and I do this to save a little time with
the press later on John McCain received
the a fake and phony dossier do you hear
about the dossier it was paid for by
crooked Hillary Clinton right
and john mccain got it he got it and
what did he do didn't call me he turned
it over to the FBI hoping to put me in
jeopardy and that's not the nicest thing
to do i endorsed him at his request and
I gave him the kind of funeral that he
wanted which as president I had to
approve I don't care about this I didn't
get thank you
that's okay we sent him on the way but I
wasn't a fan of John McCain so now what
we could say is now we're all set I
don't think I have to answer that
question but the press keeps what do you
think of McCain what do you think not my
kind of guy but some people like him and
I think that's great